your axes we're going to label but
according to the data that we've got
okay your vertical AXI axis is gonna be
people it's just gonna be a tally it'd
be one two three four five six
whatever in fact they go up to it'll go
up to how many people do we have in the
ridge in there
2 4 6 8 10 12 14 16 18 20 21 it's gonna
go up 21 if you've got 1 2 3
the next number should be 4 if the next
number is 10 then the scale is wrong
well I think if I can see that things
are roughly in the right spot then I'll
be okay
I'll be happy okay now that's your
vertical axis your horizontal axis is
gonna be the information that you
provided me namely price price so you
have copied the spreadsheet where
everyone actually inputted the data and
it's all here now we need to do a bit of
work with it remember as we went through
the four questions okay the four
questions went up in price they went up
in price right so the first question we
should expect the lowest numbers and the
last question we should expect the
highest numbers make sense okay now I
have no idea like I literally don't side
with this Tanya I have no idea what's
gonna go on this price axis here I'm
gonna go off the data that you supplied
me and you are going to as well so
here's what I'd like you to do take your
first column of data that's this one
here I keep forgetting my plugin okay
so I've called it column B this would be
their solar that this product is is
probably a bit dicey okay what we're
gonna do is in Excel and if you're in
Google Docs there's a very very similar
kind of setting in Excel I'm gonna go to
da da da
leisa I'm gonna sort this okay I'm gonna
sort this it's probably gonna ask you if
you want to expand the selection and do
like this other stuff as well I'm not
going to for reasons that will become
clear in a minute I want to sort this
according to what's the lowest number
okay so if I say and you'll notice it
just automatically on the select that
first were there cuz it knows that's a
question it's what we call a head up
okay
it's unselected that's so now this is
the data I'm interested in and I want it
to be sorting on values smallest to
largest that's the default and that's
what I was when I came became what am I
gonna get okay
so someone who said fifty cents right
that is close enough to zero that I
guess we're going to make this over here
you know zero dollars okay zero not
that's the lowest number okay so I'm
gonna undo that I just wanted to do that
so I knew where my snail go and now I
look the biggest possible number so how
should I do that one how about you read
it how am I gonna do it like Rowling
just looked manually for how I do is in
a smart way
okay so I'll go I'll go over to the big
column of a the last column real high
like that
this time just so I don't have to scroll
because I am super ultra lazy right
instead of sorting from smallest to
largest
I want the big number right at the top
just so I can see it straight away so
I'm gonna sort that why just to smallest
makes it okay so somebody's put in a
hundred and ten now we have a choice of
what to do here right this is really
really good I'm so glad I'm just curious
I'm just curious who put in a hundred
and ten well okay well I want to
understand so what did all that
individually fine okay yeah thumbs up
now we have a choice as mathematicians
and kind of what we're doing now is kind
of statistical analysis so statisticians
we have a choice of statisticians about
what to do with this data
okay now we can legitimately if we
choose we can ignore this data why would
we do that it's an outlier very good
that's such an important word that we
should all drive that down under we're
doing the trap outliers right outliers
are literally that kind of data that lie
outside of where all the rest of the
data is right look at the next price
immediately after that it's almost half
that number right so our outlier is
double way out and all of these guys are
kind of at least reasonably close
together 60 though it's above 50 it's
not an outlier it's still in the main
body of the data
okay so we could include it but I think
it's probably wise to ignore this a liar
does all it gets done all the time okay
so that means our biggest now bar will
be 60 okay sir on our horizontal axis
I'm going all the way from zero dollars
all the way up onto your
now at this point here the amount of
detail that we put it here is literally
whatever we want
okay if you have a looking further down
the data right you can see for instance
that these amounts of money adhere
they're within just one or two dollars
of each other over here they're also all
quite close okay so I could if I wanted
to just go 0 10 20 30 40 50 60 I could
if I wanted but I'm going to lose a lot
of important detail it's in the
information here right so probably going
up intends not a sufficient amount of
detail did get this as mathematicians we
get to decide this kind of thing
depending what is useful to us okay so
I'm not going to put a up all of the
markings on here because I'm taking too
much time at the moment okay I'm just
gonna put on enough to start right so
I've put on a halfway point cuz that's
quite easy to see even if you don't have
a ruler right I want to put another
halfway point here in here
and we'll stop there for a minute stop
there for me now if you've got extra
colors there this will be useful if you
don't it's totally okay when you said
spurred this into your computer maybe
you can add the colors in there but now
I'm going to undo this sorting and I'm
gonna think about each column as we go
and how I can work with so France it's
question 1 question 1 what price should
be so low that you would question the
quality of this pizza ok I can track
along how many people think a certain
price is so low that they're like no way
I'm not gonna buy that ok for instance
let's go back to this
okay Shh
can you see let's have a look at these
numbers here right and you should sort
of say you can see something similar
when you look at these numbers there is
from zero all the way up until ten hey
zero up and tilted so what I've got here
is that if I think about say okay let's
go right to the top of one dollar how
many people remember how many we've got
internal okay how many people think a
dollar is so low that you would question
the quality does pizza right now you
might say ah one person right but that's
that is not actually true right if I got
that pizza and I labeled it with the
dollar right raise your hand if you
think that'd be too low to pay its a
answer everyone who put these numbers
right hands down everyone put these down
this just said no way I'm not touching
that thing cuz even if it was two
dollars I wouldn't touch it or even
those three dollars I wouldn't touch it
okay anyone who put in these numbers
talking about the first points price
points I'll ask you to take it seriously
okay well I'm thinking about buying it
though cuz we're talking about selling
things right you guys weren't interested
in selling those sausages for free I'm
just giving you and say where'd you eat
this right we were saying are you gonna
buy it
Keating's good enough to actually put
down so I can say out of the 21 people
right a hundred percent of those 21
people said that zero dollars was too
long
it's true though okay but then when I
went to one dollar I only had 20 people
who would have thought that right if I
go over to say everything's really in
here
if I go over to a point like you get to
do this in this house it's really really
handy if you go over and select all the
people on the five there we go
okay now you could go ahead and you can
count that like a monkey but you don't
have to because excels better for you
right down there automatically it says
count 12
okay so there are 12 people who if the
price was less than $5 $5 over somewhere
like they're 12 people who would have
said okay that price is too low and I
can fill in the rest of this
I'd like you to expand on your piece of
paper that's why I got you to get a
piece of paper out I want you to look at
this data and think about how many
people we think this is this price is
too low forget it I'm not touching this
thing okay and we're gonna get a line
comes down like this okay our highest
price but someone said was too low it
was $10 right this person's got some
high tastes okay so at $10 down here
I've got normal people
okay so I have this line tracking down
like this okay can you see that so I
want you to complete that line use the
data you've got it in front of you and
complete that one I'm going to draw it a
little bit differently so it doesn't
quite reflect the data we've got because
there's a bit of a on a gamble on my
part to see what dollar would give me
okay you can see is clear downward trim
this makes sense right as you go further
rock as you increase the price less and
less people will say now that's
Kilis right eventually you get to some
point where it's high enough such that
no one would say that price is too low
okay so the graph is going to look
something like this a normal graph will
do something like that
roughly okay for the exact item that you
provided me that got a had a really
sharp drop-off but it was partly because
of the nature of the product that I
chose okay
usually it kind of tapers off also when
you have a wider group of people you've
got larger numbers of people who have
like more income whereas you guys are
pretty much all the same so this line
here in blue right this is my two cheap
line so I'm gonna have some colors here
and so will you so you'll need a bit of
a legend to you to explain what's going
on so there's my to cheat line that was
question 1 now question 2 question 2 is
my bargain line my good valued line
right now let me ask you this question
okay how do you think my question 2 line
which is gonna be great
I'm gonna call it the bargain line do
you think the bargain line would be
above or below this line is it gonna be
above or below think about it think
about the way we answer the question it
should be yeah above into the right yeah
because as we went through the questions
the numbers just got high so actually
what most people will find is there's
some point at which we say everyone
agrees everyone agrees a hundred percent
of people say yeah for that price I
think that's good value okay or below
but then the line does exactly the same
thing that were too cheap line does it
comes down okay so our two lines here
one that represents no way I wouldn't
buy it below there right and this line
which is like oh yeah that's that's good
that's on the that's on the bargain side
of things right that's good value these
are it starts to get interesting when
you cross over to question three
question three is exactly in Reverse
it says what price should be high enough
to think this is a premium product okay
now some people are gonna look at that
pizza and they're gonna have a pretty
low bar right so they're gonna say oh
wow
fall like five dollars I think that's a
premium product okay now most people
will not say that they're only a very
small number of people who would believe
that such a low price it quoits to such
a premium product but that number will
increase that number will increase as
you raise the price can we get the
lights boosts okay so in red here we've
got our premium line premium okay this
is not too expensive this is not too
expensive it looks like it must be just
sort of upmarket stuff our last question
our fourth question was too expensive
think again be thoughtful with this on
where do you expect this line to go in
relation to our on the lines very good
very good these prices are higher again
right see they're going to the right
okay
so they're gonna do something like this
okay so I have four lines here and now
we can draw some conclusions I don't
hold